we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's kind of a weird question about my
plastic surgery background take a listen
to this
hi david so you're like a media tv type
person so okay i assume you've had a
nose job
i'm thinking about getting a nose job as
well i have some issues with breathing i
have
nasal valve collapse
it doesn't happen all the time
but sometimes at night i can't breathe
out of my left nostril that typically
happens
um i'm just wondering like what your
opinions are
on uh
a uh just like a functional surgery like
that just to fix the nasal collapse like
should i do that or the other thing is
i'm
like way overweight so like if i lose
weight i might not have the same issues
and then i've heard about like viewing
you can do like exercises to oh my god
okay so there's a lot going on there
listen you've got to talk to an
otolaryngologist also known as an ear
nose and throat doctor uh i have not had
a nose job
listen if i went and got a nose job do
you think this is the nose i'd be asking
for that does not seem uh that does not
seem appropriate no i have not had a
nose job um
maybe you have a deviated septum who
knows but my specialty is podiatry not
ent stuff so you've actually got to go
and talk to a doctor i don't know how
much of this voicemail is serious but i
know many people
who
have had
uh corrective nose surgeries
mostly deviated septums
it was quite a recovery took several
weeks if not into a couple of months and
yes i am aware
that sometimes
people who
have a deviated septum will say you know
what i think i'm actually going to get a
nose job and the plastic surgeon can
correct the deviated septum while
they're in there might as well do both
at once but that is not medical advice
i'm not bill o'reilly okay
i don't have a concierge service where i
give you all sorts of advice we have a
fantastic bonus show today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad you know i can think
of no greater endorsement of the bonus
show than the fact that alex jones
really doesn't like it indiana lawmakers
have approved the first state abortion
ban since roe v wade was overturned
it's happening
it's happening
u.s automakers say that 70 percent of
electric vehicle models would not
qualify for the tax credit currently in
the senate bill why not
i will explain and thirdly new zealand
is considering changing its name
to confront its troubled
colonial past hmm
have they gone woke
we will talk about it on today's bonus
show you can sign up at joinpacman.com
and get instant access
the normal prices for membership are
really low and listen
so many of us
spend 40 80 120 200 if you add up
internet service
netflix some people have cable some
people have hulu discovery plus
paramount plus apple tv all these
different things some people spend over
200
with the coupon code obama
you can get a membership for two bucks a
month and you're really supporting us
directly if you have a cable
subscription
something like four bucks a month goes
to fox news you might hate fox news
okay
with the memberships on our website from
every dollar we get 98 cents the other
two cents just goes to processing the
payments okay
join pacman.com
very cheap
great perks and you are really
you are sure you are confident that the
money is actually going where you are
being told it is going which is into
producing shows and more content
speaking of more content soon i will
tell you about the new personal finance
channel that we we are launching which i
think is going to be absolutely
tremendous folks alright see you on the
bonus show or otherwise back here
tomorrow